my mom and dad were really good at like
asking me every year are you still
enjoying it do you still want to do this
you're like what am I going to do go
back to school like that's not as fun as
this
Harry Potter
who are you rubius Hagrid keeper of keys
and grounds at Hogwarts
of course you don't know all about
Hogwarts sorry no
no
blow me Harry didn't you ever wonder
where your mom and dad learned at all
want more
you're a wizard Harry
you know I've read I think the first two
books I was not a big reader so uh so I
was not as into it as like a lot of my
friends were I don't think I was like
thinking particularly deeply about the
characters or acting when I was that age
the people I really admired were the
people that like didn't mystify acting
too much who were just able to like come
to set and do it Imelda Staunton David
thulis Gary Oldman Michael Gambon
they're all people that can be very
normal and chatting away and then can
just turn it on on action they're people
that particularly Imelda was one of the
people that I always just looked at and
went like you're so good and it's so
effortless because she will be just
chatting away to everyone and having a
nice life and day and then able to give
an incredibly terrifying or intense
performance you deserve to be funny
don't you Mr Potter
Michael Gammon could do that to a
frustrating degree he learned that he
could as when I was a teenager like he
can make me laugh very very easily
making me laugh like right up until the
word action at which point I was pretty
much unable to recover and he could just
like Snap into a performance with just
like inherent gravitas and charm forgive
my more Christmas Harry
I'm an old man
yeah he's awesome there is so much on
Potter that was so intense and so crazy
you don't even think about at the time
because you're just like yeah they're
building a tank where d-stage used to be
they're just like building a tank and
they're going to be filming underwater
for six weeks I had like a log book of
all the hours that I'd done underwater
like it was it was really cool I've
heard that we average like seven seconds
of footage a day or something like of
usable footage but again those are one
of those things that you go like I will
never do that again and if I do I'll be
one of the only people who's done it
before it was one of those moments that
you look back and go God that's special
those ones on the fourth film the whole
the dragon sequence on the fourth film
one shot on the sick film I think where
I start off underneath the water and I
was on a wire so I was holding myself uh
by a rope under the surface of the water
and then on action I let go and they
pulled me on the wire so I flew out of
the water and there was like a ring of
fire around me so I was just like
bursting out of the surface of the water
through a ring of fire it's phenomenal
that they allowed me to do that myself
and like again I'll never probably be on
a job where they do let me do that kind
of stuff I think every director kind of
came on at a point we needed them to and
when we were all ready to be then taken
to another you know development
developmental stage of our acting I
don't think anyone else could have
started the series in the way that Chris
did I don't think anyone else could have
wrangled 30 kids and kept us all focused
and happy um in the way that he did
Alfonso when he came on you know we were
all starting to become like more intense
brooding teenagers and so he sort of
came on at the right moment to
capitalize on that and the same goes for
Mike is like this bombastic huge
character which is exactly what you
needed for like the fourth film and book
and then David Yates to finish them all
off like I mean I really feel like
particularly the fifth film was where I
like learned a lot particularly from
working with Gary and in scenes with
Gary with David I think that's sort of
where I started to get more of a handle
on like what acting was what matters is
the part we choose to act on
that's who we really are
I'm incredibly lucky to have worked with
all of them but honestly the person that
I think had the greatest influence on me
out of all of those is Chris Columbus
when Chris came back for the 20th
anniversary reunion last year he came to
the studios and there were people on the
set who were running across set to see
this director that they had not seen in
20 years and they remembered him and he
remembered them and it was there are so
few people in the industry that can like
Inspire that in people like that you
genuinely the crews of the first two
part of films would have would have
followed Chris Columbus into hell you
know they would we just loved him uh so
much and he was and I think a huge
amount of his enthusiasm for like being
on set
um is sort of where I take mine from and
the reason I think I love the job so
much is is in no small part due to him
Swiss army man
I know I know it sounds dumb but I
really thought for a moment that that
maybe just maybe there was a reason that
you
everyone has a thing of like that's so
crazy it's such a crazy idea how did you
how did they convince you I was like I
didn't see like it seemed like not like
a normal film like it's not like you
know it's obviously got some Fantastical
crazy elements to it but the combination
of meeting them and talking to them
seeing their videos and reading the
script I was like yeah I want to be
involved in this and I fully didn't know
what I was going to do as this character
for the longest time like I had no idea
what Manny was gonna be and ultimately
like going to set and just sort of
putting yourself in their hands because
they knew exactly what they wanted it to
be that was one of the truly one of the
best experiences I've ever had and
probably the film that I'm like proudest
of how did you get so far from home
I I ran away but
that's it doesn't matter that's what's
important is
you remembering your life okay what is
life
oh okay when I was like practicing at
home and just doing like weird Manny
voices and facial expressions everything
I was doing was kind of just slipping
towards zombie every time I would say
something or move I would be trying to
communicate the fact that he is dead the
lesson in that for me was having the
makeup on the first time being made up
to ba corpse suddenly I was like oh I
looked dead I don't have to act Dead all
the time because this is doing the work
for me I can be this sweet little
character but he'll just look like a
dead sweet little character because of
what else is is going on
[Music]
I remember Jurassic Park what you were
just singing the theme song
the Brachiosaurus
I don't know
I don't know you remember the song and
he pulls one of the most incredible
actors I've ever worked with he carries
both the film and literally me
throughout the movie I'm the one getting
to go in and just do a crazy weird
performance he gets to do that but also
has to like be the the engine of the
film and the the Beating Heart of it and
yeah I mean he's he's incredible in that
and bless him there were so many times
when they had like they had made a dummy
for him to carry around and there was a
lot of the time I think he just like
wanted the weight of the real me so he
genuinely is carrying me around a lot in
that movie if I get hit by lightning
tomorrow or something if there's one
scene that I could pick from everything
I've ever done to just be the thing that
like lasts after me it would be the
scene on the bus from Swiss army man she
sits alone just like every other day and
looks out the window lost in her
thoughts you know that look
just as alone as you are but she doesn't
have to be you could talk to her
tell her you'd love to sit next to her
today and every other day because life
is short and no one deserves to ride the
bus alone I want this to stop it's not
working no
she's too beautiful
I can't talk to her now what if I say
something stupid I just want to die
bones
hey egg what does it feel like to get
away with murder I'm gonna comment on
the fire at the lab in Tacoma last night
have you heard that the police have a
new witness you should ask God to save
your soul for what you did just yes the
devil's to punish whoever the [ __ ]
children egg parish is the uh local guy
who has been dating this girl Marin for
many years she has been murdered at the
beginning of the film and the entire
town thinks that he has done it he's
also got like a drinking problem so he
can't fully account for the the knights
and and he is worried that he might have
had something to do with it and doesn't
know what's happened and then he wakes
up one morning uh with tiny tiny bumps
on the side of his head which then burst
through and are the beginnings of
Devil's horns as they continue to grow
he realizes that they have like a
strange effect on people where they kind
of make people give in to or admit their
worst impulses and desires he sort of
uses that to figure out who really
killed his girlfriend but I told him
that your girlfriend forgot her jacket
so I followed her into the parking lot
and I saw you drive back and scream that
you were gonna kill her but you know
that's not true and then I saw you drag
her into your car and then you drove off
what why the hell would you say all that
because I want to be in all the
newspapers and on TV I want to be the
star witness at your trial you're such a
[ __ ] crazy liar it's a very dark
comedy with like very strong magical
realism element to it also made by one
of the most talented directors I've ever
worked with Alex Azure I love that movie
it's a crazy film but I so enjoyed it
also a lot of snake work on that film
how's it going where's that snake doing
around your neck I made a new friend
early on I wanted to you know try and
get a reputation for being someone who
wanted to try lots of different stuff
obviously you want to be known as an
actor who's just saying lots of
different stuff rather than just a
character what a specific character you
know everything I do is I want it to be
different from the last thing I've done
and everything else I not everything I
do is like a comment on Harry Potter or
an attempt to distance myself from it
and I think I knew at the time that was
never going to be achieved by just one
film like it was gonna take just
building up a body of work with that had
a variety in it was was going to be the
thing that made that separation wasn't
going to be one thing that everyone sees
and goes oh he is no longer Harry Potter
to us because that's that's just that's
not how it works yeah that period of
like horns Killy Darlings those are the
first forays into like doing some other
stuff
Kill Your Darlings
Vision declares well claims this is
better proclaims the death of morality
the expression of self the true
uninhibited uncensored expression of the
self words always empty words well what
do you suggest the derangement of these
senses
like anything it was like a lot of a lot
of accent work on that one particularly
because he's a little bit more specific
than my sort of generic American a lot
of like research and reading and his
Diaries again which are mostly later but
there is a lot of stuff from early on as
well I think that was the first film I
shot outside the UK that's the closest
thing I have to a process now which is
again not much but like I I a lot of it
I gained from working with John on that
film and he sort of introduced me to
like a lot of just ways of breaking down
a script that are very practical and
useful for an actor it's embarrassingly
basic to actually say them but basically
it's like John introduced me to the
concept of like action verbs and
actioning a script so like going through
something and just finding a bunch of
different so rather than thinking of
what's going on internally in the
character which can be quite a
self-conscious way to work there's
something about finding an action verb
which you are trying to do to the other
person so it's not something you're
trying to do with yourself it's trying
to have an effect on the other person
that's why it's like embarrassing to
make this like very basic acting 101 but
like no one had ever explained it to me
so it was nice to for John to do that
you may either retract this fiction as
your final or you may choose to be
expelled what will it be
fine
consider me expelled
look this remains with us
I'm kind of somebody who has a general
interest in history anyway so I feel
like learning more about the time period
And how that would have been formed and
learning about like young Allen's life
it was really like was fascinating you
know I don't think when when you get on
to set that you're really playing any of
that it's just that's just sort of all
useful context to absorb sort of before
you go into something
guns are kembo
it's very hard not to be Charmed by a
script where the main protagonist has
guns for hands after about page 10.
two scenes later it's he's like trying
to go to the toilet with Guns For Hands
and I was like great you've got a
premise you're fully exploring it I'm
probably gonna do this movie I I just
loved the fact that it was like
you had like a 90-minute shot out of a
cannon just adrenaline ride of insane
action and Samara weaving being [ __ ]
cool and psychotic Jason created great
characters and it is simply that thing
of like you've had a fun idea but it's
not just that you've had a fun idea
you've like created a really good plot
around it and you are you're fully like
exploring it for comedy because like I
love action films but for me to do an
action film I feel like there has to be
like a certain amount of physical comedy
involved as well and the fact that like
though this action characters like
special skill is running away I was like
yeah this is this is the action guy for
me
foreign
[Music]
sneakers inside so I could actually run
in them so the thing was hard was
putting things in Pockets but I could
fully take something out of my pockets
with just the gun hands they spend
enough time with them and you eventually
will get good and they're genuinely
useful as uh shoe horns you can for that
it's it's almost like they were made for
it
yeah
that was one of the leaks that the
paparazzi I think it's there's been like
a couple over the years where like a
picture of me in my mind clearly at work
doing something will come out and there
will be like a response to it of like 90
of people being like oh this looks like
a crazy movie but there seems always
like a fairly high percentage of people
being like has Dan Radcliffe lost his
[ __ ] mind so yeah that was that was
one of them but it was great again and
it all helps like the moment that that
started happening I was like well people
are going to be interested in this movie
then you know and it is a it's a it's a
great image
The Lost City
come with me to the island translate
these symbols and help me find that the
crown of Fire
can name your price
fully decline
[Music]
well
I can't say I'm not disappointed
but I understand how you feel
will you at least let us give you a ride
oh no thank you I'll call from my own
car and I'll just
he's not really a bad guy in this film
and he's doing an insane accent so it
Bears no resemblance really but Tim
Curry in the movie Congo just act as
when you see them having a great time
playing a weird kind of a villainous of
someone whose motivations are sketchy
anyone like that I feel like Alan
[ __ ] I I work with Alan a few years
ago but he's also like played some
fantastic villains over the years I feel
like they're they're people to reference
and also just a certain type of Posh
English boy you know entitled
slightly stupid I've met a few so that I
could draw on them
where am I
um you're on my plane
it's nice isn't it the seats are made of
mama llama leather well I'm getting off
your plate I'm chain me that's your
seatbelt
did you chloroform me people actually do
that oh
well you know it's a classic for a
reason he thinks sonner bullet is going
to love being kidnapped basically he is
convinced that if she just thinks about
this she will find this cool the prep
for that was really just I don't know
learning the lines and having as much
fun as possible being horrible Cassandra
Bullock honestly getting to work with
her was such a thrill I grew up on the
Potter films obviously working with
Maggie Smith and Richard Harris but I
didn't have like a inherent knowledge of
who those people were like I did I
hadn't watched you know a man called
horse when I was a kid so I didn't know
what the significance but I did very
much grow up watching Sandra Bullock and
stuff so yeah to get to to get to work
with her was incredibly cool
miracle workers
striking out hard here man
I've tried telling jokes to this guy
I've complimented him I even told him my
real name
all that happened was he had a seizure
oh well um yeah I don't know much about
profits but I'll try and help thanks bud
I appreciate it
I know you must be busy well actually
I'm not really that busy I don't think
anyone downstairs really need me anymore
oh well I need you big time
okay well yeah great what's uh what's
the plan
hit him hard with a tornado uh what I
read what in God's name which is the
book that the first season of miracle
workers was based on as well as the last
girlfriend on Earth which became called
something else uh the man seeking woman
Simon is a brilliant brilliant writer
incredibly funny also incredibly warm
and there's a sweetness to his writing
as well and yeah wrote two fantastic
seasons of of miracle workers and then I
was like to point out just because
they're fantastic as well is that two
guys called Dan murk and Robert padnick
sort of show on the the last two seasons
of the show in the Oregon Trail and the
one we've just finished TBS have let us
do one of the weirdest little shows on
TV for the last few years and I will be
forever grateful for it because
particularly the one we've just done is
uh We've really like taken some big
swings in terms of like high concept
weird jokes and stuff so I'm I'm very
excited for people to say it yeah the
fact of it was announced Technology
Series I was like this is ideal I just
get to come back and work with Steve
buscelemy and and this group of actors
and get Simon Rich's writing every year
and and then Dana Roberts and yeah it's
just it's a real it's a dream
weird the Al Yankovic story
honestly most of Al's notes to me were
musical were like stuff about the the
playing of the accordion or um of lyrics
and songs and stuff he was very specific
about that but other than that he was
kind of just like gave me free reign to
create my own version of him I think
he's he's happy with it so I'm yeah so
that's that's you know I'm delighted
this was particularly quick this shoot
but like Swiss army man was 20
three days Kelly Darlings was like 24
days another film I won't mention
because it's really bad and you're not
even gonna ask me about it so it's fine
was like 16 days
um I actually love working that way I
think on Potter growing up you know we
things took a long long time which was
great in a way because it meant I've got
like I can I got sort of stamina across
the course of a shoot and I don't get
too tired but it's also the feeling of
like doing five or six scenes in a day
and having achieved all of them is
really really fulfilling I think if you
asked our director he would probably
have like I think we all would have
liked like maybe a couple more on this
but you know it is what it is and and
you make the best of it and truly the
making of This film is like a testament
to to what you can do if you're prepared
we draw like a Massive Action scene in
like four hours at one point which is
I'm very very proud of that